Speaker 1: I have a story today about how
sometimes we can find like a point of agreement
with right wingers and then very quickly see
that point of agreement devolve into them
having some of the absolute worst political
instincts.
I can imagine where the solutions we imagine
to the points of agreement couldn't be more
different.
And we've been covering the rising unrest
in Cuba.
Cuba's covid situation is rapidly devolving
into a public health chaos that we've not
seen throughout the pandemic in Cuba.
The economy is further collapsing.
Inflation is starting to explode, and we're
not talking about five percent.
Thanks to more Internet access in Cuba, the
Cuban people are now coordinating and hitting
the streets in protest.
This is a complicated situation in which I,
as an anti authoritarian left winger, oppose
the Cuban regime.
I do not know how anyone calling themselves
progressives could support a regime that came
to power with Fidel Castro in 1959, stayed
in power.
He stayed in power for 49 years until 2008,
and then handed power to his brother, Raul
Castro.
That's not democracy.
It's also an authoritarian police state with
total control over just about every aspect
of people, people's lives.
So as an anti anti authoritarian progressive
who's in favor of democracy, northern European
social democracy, etc, I am against that.
There is no way I could be for that.
And also, many Cuban-Americans oppose that
regime.
Many of them are right wingers, but they oppose
the regime, often for different reasons.
The current mayor of Miami is Cuban-American
Francis Suarez.
He's the son of the first Cuban born mayor
of Miami.
The current mayor's father, Javier Suarez,
was also the mayor of Miami Pre.
Asleep and he went on a Francis Suarez that
is went on Fox News yesterday and was talking
about what's going on in Cuba, and somehow
he ends up with, you know, maybe the US military
should bomb Cuba.
So why how could that possibly be an action
that would improve what's going on in Cuba
if what we want to do is help the Cuban people?
So let's look at the full clip and you'll
see that along with a long list of terrible
instincts, there's this idea of military action.
OK, let's listen.
Speaker 2: A repressive government and a cruel
US embargo.
They deserve policies that empower them and
help them improve their lives.
Do you think that President Biden, looking
at this situation will lift that embargo?
And do you think that's what he should do?
Speaker 3: No, I don't think the embargo is
is cruel at all.
And I think the Cuban people are asking for
a lifting of the embargo.
Speaker 1: OK, so to two things already.
First of all, the Cuban embargo, you know,
cruel or not, is completely hypocritical.
The Cuban embargo is based on the idea that
the United States disagrees with Cuba's system
of government.
I'm with you.
I disagree with it as well.
I also disagree with Saudi Arabia's system
of government.
And yet we continue that relationship almost
completely unquestioned, even by most of the
Democratic establishment.
So, again, if we want to credibly say we want
to help the Cuban people, the Cuban embargo
hasn't forced them to change their system
of government for 60 years or whatever the
case is at this point in time, 60, 60 something
year, 62 years.
And it's just hurting the Cuban people.
Number two, when Suarez says the protests
from the Cuban people aren't against the embargo,
listen, they may not be overtly against the
embargo, but much of what is leading Cuba
to be what it is right now is related to that
embargo.
Not all of it.
Part of it is the system of government in
Cuba.
And I vehemently and vehemently believe that
that has to change.
But to say the protests have nothing to do
with the embargo, that that ignores context
completely.
But let's keep going
Speaker 3: out on the streets every single
day talking about the failure of the communist
regime to provide for its people.
And I don't understand why that's so difficult
for people to understand.
Speaker 1: So it can be both.
Francis, we can both say the authoritarian
police state anti-democratic regime that's
been in place since 1959 is unlikely to be
great for the people of Cuba.
And that's true.
And the American embargo also makes it worth
both things can be true.
Then we get into the military has
Speaker 3: failed for six decades.
And what should be being contemplated right
now is a coalition of potential military action
in Cuba, similar to what has happened in both
administrations, in both Republican and Democrat
administrations and Republican with Bush and
Panama.
They deposed Noriega and that country had
peace,
Speaker 1: military action, military action.
I mean, listen, it's a different debate, but
one might argue you talk about military action
if there's a real risk to the United States
or our interests in Cuba, you know, other
than Guantanamo Bay, I don't know exactly
what interests we have.
There's a national security threat.
Cuba having a large population that has almost
nothing and being oppressed by that regime.
Military action.
Come on.
It is not a national security threat, the
likes of which we would be talking about military
action, whether that's bombing, whether that's
an assassination campaign by a covert arm
of the military or whatever.
This is just the epitome of I'm against the
Cuban regime.
As an anti authoritarian leftist, Francis
Suarez is against the Cuban regime based on
the vague idea of being against communism.
And we're both against the regime.
But military action, that's the last thing
that's on my mind.
And it is just another example of how even
when we find points of agreement with some
of these folks, their solutions are very much
the wrong ones.
And this has been a big thing with populism.
I've said before one of the dangers of populist
rhetoric and falling for it.
Is that populist rhetoric from left wingers
and populist rhetoric from right wingers sounds
very similar, and then you get to the solutions
and man of the people, Tucker Carlson is saying,
well, we need a solution because soon Black
Lives Matter is going to take your house.
And brown people coming in are the problem,
right, of immigrants make the country dirty,
as he has previously said.
And that's the pernicious nature of that rhetoric.
So let me know your thoughts.
You can find me on Twitter at David Pakman.
Remember that August 16th is the 16th anniversary
of The David Pakman Show.
We are having a huge membership blowout.
My lawyer and accountant are beating down
the door saying, sir, don't do it.
Don't do this.
Don't you, can't do it, sir.
It's going to be too big of a discount, sir.
Sure.
Exactly.
But we're doing it on August 16th, and you
can get on our newsletter by signing up at
David Pakman Dotcom.
Hope you'll participate.
Will be back right after this.
I would love it if you signed up for a David
Pakman show membership at Join Pakman Dotcom,
not only are you supporting the show, but
you get stuff including the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show, and we
do an extra show every day.
I don't want to call it the fun half like
Sam Ceder does, but it's pretty fun.
It's not bad.
And it's won some awards awards we've created
specifically to award ourselves, but certainly
awards nonetheless.
Sign up at Join Pakman dot com.
You can use the coupon code better twenty
one to get yourself a discount.